we're all aware of that special
relationship between the UK and the USA
and as you can probably tell from my
accent American TV featured heavily in
my childhood but Donald Trump is not a
friend many people think that old Uncle
Sam will replace everything we might
lose from the EU but let's be clear mr.
America first has no intention of
putting the UK's interest first he sees
trade as I win you lose
he'll ensure the UK market is flooded
with American beef which along with
wiping out UK farming would increase the
need for border checks in Northern
Ireland Trump's made a promise to the
people he needs to vote for him next
year that he'll make sure the health
systems of any future trade partner has
to pay more for medicines so that
Americans pay less that obviously
includes our NHS which pays a third of
the price for its drugs now a foreign
power whose explicit intention is to
damage the thing that literally saves
lives in this country can only be
described as hostile
[Music]
what is his peculiar isolationist world
you're trying to take us into I'm afraid
Fleming you're blinded by your hatred of
Donald Trump the person the United
States has been in a special
relationship with Britain since Winston
Churchill coined the phrase in 1946
we've got huge cultural links we've got
defense links and intelligence links
through NATO and United Nations Security
Council and you know what we do a lot of
flipping business with them we're one of
their biggest export markets and there
is a great potential for a free new
trade deal when we leave you when we
eventually leave the wretched EU that is
which can't come soon enough for me not
for you of course and and I think you've
just got to get over the fact I'm
personally Francia because he's a he's a
misogynist and you probably think he's a
racist to the United States is that he
is the leader of the free world and we
got to do business with him and the
sooner we get on with it the better
you're suggesting that we just don't do
business with Trump at all but I don't
understand how any deal we do could be
that damaging Trump would be selling to
66 million British people and we would
be selling to 327 million
American people which from where am
sitting is a win-win situation and you
talk about he's a hostile foreign power
because he because he was America first
it's not a crime for any leader of any
country to put his country and his
people first which is exactly why lots
of people want to leave you because we
want to put we want to put Britain first
you know and I think you'll find that
that globalization has harmed America
hugely which is why his his mantra is
America first more than half the
manufacturing jobs in America have been
lost because of globalization see
neither of you have dealt with the
actual point that I made it's not about
his general attitude of America first
it's about the specific intentions that
he has in a near-future trade he said
them on camera to his own people his
electorate he said he will end what he
calls the global freeloading of health
care now if you think that we'll just
say well no don't worry the NHS will be
off the tape we've said it let's go look
at it this way look at this way first of
all in the EU negotiations how many red
lines have we crossed that we laid down
the clear red lines as for what happened
you wanna make clear comparison put it
this way the EU and the u.s. they
negotiate they were trying to negotiate
a trade deal there was a risk that it
might lead to the privatization of the
NHS so we kicked up a fuss are we
managed to get a joint declaration from
the UK from the US and the EU but
nothing that agreement could damage our
ability to nationalize or we nationalize
health care so the NHS was protected
from privatization under that agreement
now compare that with now we are heading
down a very dangerous road you pointed
out the fact that there is a larger
number of consumers on the American side
that's the essence of trade you say do
exactly what you see you say do exactly
what I want you have access to this
massive market that I control it is the
its size matters in international trade
can I just say about your great friends
in the European Union because of their
behavior this week we've got sanctions
being put on a number of British goods
including scotch whiskey and that is
because the EU would judge by the World
Trade Organization to the legally been
pouring state aid into Airbus against
Boeing so don't tell me that the EU is
the perfect answer family when this week
we've seen British industry scotch
whiskey being hammered
because of the EU Donald Trump has also
said he wants to do a big trade deal
with the United Kingdom but of course
you're not willing to believe that and
he's already our biggest trading partner
already I mean I it's really weird that
you're not hearing what the US is
actually telling us about the basis on
which they will do future trade deals
with the UK Woody Johnson the US
ambassador has has told us has told us
in British media interviews that he
would expect British health care to be
on the table and he would expect food
standards to be changed now that is that
that that is the crucial thing about
trade with the US that it would require
a lowering of standards one of the
things that is a most concern to Britain
is food standards it would be hormone
injected beef and chlorinated chicken
one of the things Donald Trump's
administration they're in favor of
brexit because it makes us vulnerable
Mike Pence has done a glowing
recommendation of brexit and a quick
warning this excerpt doesn't quite
include flash photography the United
States stands without apology for a
strong prosperous and free United
Kingdom it was my great honour to meet
with Prime Minister Johnson at 10
Downing Street I offered the president's
for God
if the United States of America supports
the United Kingdom's decision to leave
the European I believe if we're to
ensure that the 21st century witnesses
of Renaissance commerce between
freedom-loving countries
[Music]
we'll stand side-by-side
shoulder-to-shoulder and we will show
the world how free and fair trade can
promote prosperity and peace across the
globe it's amazing how about music just
that shows that he wanted the car must
have watched some different video
because that shows that he wants it to
be vulnerable he talked about how he
wants the UK to be strong prosperous and
free he talked about a renaissance in
trade he talked about the nations
standing side-by-side that was
respectfully and after the erroneous way
to bring in that video
yes name a country in the WTO that
doesn't have a single trade deal with
anyone this is really important this is
really important brexit a No Deal
breakfast specifically means you become
the only country in the WTO that doesn't
have a trade deal with anyone is a level
of economic vulnerability but it's
unseen in the world please respond to my
question
where was the vulnerability in the clip
you've just played is trying to mate
which is that if you are if you don't
have any trade deals and you're striding
out looking for trade deals you it gives
the person it gives the country that's
making deals with you leverage over you
because you need it more than them and
can I just say look it's just common
sense that you're going to get the most
trade and everybody who's lived to trade
in the world understands this the
countries that do best on trade do it
with countries that are near nearest to
them geographically and have the closest
alignment with the US ok but one of the
reasons we do so much trade with the
United States rate is because of a
shared language a shared history and a
shared common culture and I cannot
understand for me why you want to check
that all overboard because of your
hatred of Trump well I'd make sure that
I had the
most leverage possible and that comes
with being part of a market of 500
million people but that's how I would
have it Britain has voted against that
well we haven't voted we haven't voted
for a No Deal brac so that people
certainly did not expect a No Deal
praxis